I'M LARRY WILMORE, AND AS YOU
KNOW, TODAY IS ST. PATRICK'S
DAY, THE DAY AMERICA CELEBRATE
ITS IRISH HERITAGE BY ENGAGING
IN EVERY IRISH STEREOTYPE
IMAGINABLE.
SERIOUSLY, IF WE OBSERVED OTHER
ETHNIC HOLIDAYS THE WAY WE
OBSERVED TODAY, COLUMBUS TODAY
WOULD BE ABOUT MAKING A NICE
SUNDAY SAUCE.
WE'D CELEBRATE KWANZAA LATE.
( LAUGHTER )
THAT'S RIGHT.
ITALIANS MAKE SAUCE, BLACK
PEOPLE SHOW UP LATE.
IT'S JUST SCIENCE, PEOPLE.
BUT THINK ABOUT IT, ALL DAY
TODAY WE DRINK, WE FIGHT IN THE
STREETS.
WE DRINK.
WE PEE IN THE STREETS.
WE PUKE IN THE STREETS.
AND THEN WHEN WE'RE DONE, WE DO
A LITTLE BIT OF THIS.
>> OH!
>> Larry: OH, MY GOD.
SO THAT'S WHY YOU WEAR GREEN SO
YOUR BARF MATCHES YOUR SHIRT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT COORDINATING.
THERE IS SO MUCH DRUNK DUDE
D.N.A. ON THE SIDEWALK AFTER ST.
PATRICK'S DAY, SCIENTISTS COULD
COMBINE IT TO MAKE A
FRAT BRO SUPER VILLAIN.
THEY COULD USE THE TIMES SQUARE
BALL TO PLAY BEER PONG.
TURN GLACIERS INTO ICE LUGES.
IT WOULD BE A DISASTER.
BUT NOW, IS DRUNK AND DISORDERLY
THE WAY WE CELEBRATE EVERY
HOLIDAY NOW?
WE DRINK ON ST. PATRICK'S DAY.
WE DRINK ON CINCO DE MAYO.
PERSONALLY, I DRINK ON ARBOR
DAY.
I JUST GET A KEG AND SIT IN THE
FOREST.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
TRUE.
I DON'T KNOW.
THE TREES JUST GET ME, MAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
PERSONALLY, YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
THAT CRAZY ABOUT PARADES.
LOOK, MY PEOPLE LOVE TO MARCH.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
( LAUGHTER )
WE DO, I KNOW.
BUT SO MUCH OF OUR ( BLEEP ) IS
SO SERIOUS.
NOBODY WANTS TO RIDE ON THE
"HANDS UP DON'T SHOOT" FLOAT.
SERIOUSLY.
( LAUGHTER )
IT'S JUST NOT THAT FUN IS ALL
I'M SAYING.
YOU KNOW, I'LL BE HONEST WITH
YOU, I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU,
THAT SELMA 50th MARCH COULD
HAVE USED SOME 40s.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
SPICE IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
SO PARADES AREN'T FOR EVERYBODY,
BUT WHY ARE THERE SO MANY OF
THEM IN NEW YORK CITY?
I DON'T GET THAT. IF SOMEBODY
FROM CALIFORNIA--
LOOK, YOU HAVE THE
ST. PATRICK'S DAY PARADE.
THE MACY'S DAY PARADE.
GAY PRIDE PARADE, DOMINICAN DAY
PARADE.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
HERE'S MY PROBLEMS WITH THOSE
THREE PARADES-- PUERTO RICO AND
THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC ARE BOTH
IN THE CARIBBEAN.
THAT'S A PARADE DOUBLE DIP,
PEOPLE.
( LAUGHTER )
IT IS.
IT'S LIKE HAVING A MACY'S PARADE
AND A MACY'S HUSKY BOYS
DEPARTMENT PARADE, RIGHT?
( LAUGHTER )
I'LL LET YOU DECIDE WHO IS THE
HUSKY BOY IN THAT SCENARIO.
( LAUGHTER )
BUT AS PARADES GO, NEW YORK'S
ST. PADDY'S DAY'S CELEBRATION IS
THE IRISH MOTHER OF THEM ALL.
IT'S A FIVE-HOUR EXTRAVAGANZA
DOWN 5TH AVENUE.
IT'S FUN FOR EVERYONE. OH
RIGHT, NOT EVERYONE.
>> ORGANIZERS FOR THE NEW
YORK ANNUAL ST. PATRICK'S DAY
PARADE HAVE BANNED L.G.B.T.
GROUPS FROM MARCHING.
>> Larry: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
IS THIS-- IS THIS STILL A THING?
I MEAN, PEOPLE, THIS IS A PARADE
WHOSE MASCOT IS AN EFFETE LITTLE
MAN IN A GREEN VELVET SUIT AND
SPARKLY SHOES WHO SLIDES DOWN
RAINBOWS WHILE PLAYING A HARP.
( LAUGHTER )
I MEAN, IF YOU'RE TRYING TO HAVE
YOUR PARADE LOOK BUTCH, THAT GAY
CRUISE HAS SAILED, ALL RIGHT.
WHY WOULD THEY NOT WANT TO HAVE
THEM?
>> PARADE ORGANIZERS HAVE LONG
REFUSED ENTRY TO GAY GROUPS
BASED ON RELIGION.
>> OH!
I THOUGHT IT WAS BASED ON
HOMOPHOBIA.
( LAUGHTER )
DIDN'T KNOW.
TOOK A WILD GUESS
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I THOUGHT GAYS WERE ALLOWED TO
MARCH IN THE ST. PATRICK'S DAY
PARADE BACK IN THE EARLY 90s.
DIDN'T THAT GO WELL?
>> WE'RE HERE! WE'RE QUEER!
GET USED TO IT!
>> AIDS!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: OH, MY GOD.
BOO AIDS?
WELL, WHO WOULD NOT WANT TO BOO
AIDS, I GUESS.
( LAUGHTER )
EVEN AIDS WOULD BOO AIDS.
LET'S BE HONEST.
I TECHNICALLY AGREE WITH YOUR
WORDS, LADY.
NOT SURE I AGREE WITH YOUR
SPIRIT.
BUT SOME 24 YEARS LATER, AND
LIKELY AFTER THAT LADY'S DEATH,
PROGRESS.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER, TWO
GAY AND LESBIAN GROUPS MARCHED
IN SOUTHIE'S ST. PATRICK'S DAY
PARADE.
>> Larry: WOW, SOUTH BOSTON.
MAN, THEY USED TO BE WICKED
PREDJUDICE.
I MEAN, THAT'S A PLACE WHERE IF
YOU DON'T GREET YOUR MA WITH A
HEAD BUTT, YOU'RE SUSPECTED OF
BEING A QUEER. GOOD JOB BOSTON
NEW YORK FINALLY FEELING SHAME
FOR BEING BEHIND BOSTON HAS
DECIDED TO LET ONE KIND OF GAY
GROUP IN.
>> OUT AT NBC UNIVERSAL WILL BE
THE FIRST AND ONLY GAY GROUP TO
MARCH UNDER ITS OWN BANNER IN
THE PARADE.
>> Larry: OUT AT NBC
UNIVERSAL.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN ATTRACTION
AT THEIR THEME PARK, RIGHT?
WHAT DOES IT DO, SIMULATE ALL
THE THRILLS AND CHILLS OF COMING
OUT TO YOUR PARENTS?
AAAH!
THAT WAS SCARY.
THAT WAS SO REAL.
SO WHY IS THIS NBC GAY GROUP THE
ONLY ONE ALLOWED IN THE PARADE?
>> NBC UNIVERSAL IS THE PARENT
COMPANY OF NBC NEW YORK, WHICH
AIRS THE PARADE.
L.G.B.T. GROUPS CALL THE
INCLUSION OF ONE GROUP A PLOY BY
PARADE ORGANIZERS TO HOLD ON TO
SPONSORS.
>> Larry: SO NBC IS THE ONE
AIRING THE PARADE AND THE ONLY
GAY GROUP ALLOWED ON THE PARADE
WORKS AT NBC?
THIS SEEMS LIKE A "SCRATCH MY
BACK I'LL GIVE YOU A
REACH-AROUND" KIND OF DEAL.
BUT IRISH CATHOLICS OF NEW YORK
ARE DUG IN ON THIS ISSUE.
HONESTLY, GAYS, NO OFFENSE, BUT
DO YOU REALLY WANT TO BE IN THIS
THING?
I MEAN, PEOPLE ARE DRINKING TOO
MUCH TO EVEN NOTICE YOU
MARCHING, AND THE MUSIC SOUNDS
LIKE TWO GOATS DOING THE DEVIL'S
BUSINESS.
( LAUGHTER )
ON THE OTHER HAND, THE GAY PRIDE
PARADE IS A GLITTER BOMB OF
INCLUSION.
( LAUGHTER )
JOINING ME TO TALK MORE ABOUT
IS OUR NEW CONTRIBUTOR TO "THE
NIGHTLY SHOW," DAVID SMITHYMAN.
WELCOME, DAVID.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> THANK YOU.
OKAY, NOW.
NOW, DAVID, YOU'RE GAY.
>> I AM.
>> Larry: OH, AND IT ALSO
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE AUSTRALIAN.
>> YOU'RE A KEEN OBSERVER,
LARRY.
>> Larry: OKAY.
SO YOU WENT OUT TO THE ST.
PATRICK'S DAY'S PARADE.
>> I DID, AND I ALSO SAT DOWN
WITH ANDY HUMM, IRISH
AMERICAN GAY ACTIVIST.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
IT DOES SEEM LIKE A BUNCH OF
ANGRY DADS-- I'M AUSTRALIAN.
I'M NOT EVEN IRISH.
THIS IS AN OUTSIDE
PERSPECTIVE.
IT LOOKS LIKE EVERYONE'S ANGRY
DAD IS DRESSED UP IN THE SUIT
THEY GOT MARRIED IN AND THEY ALL
GRUMPILY WALK ALONG.
SO WHY DO YOU WANT TO BE IN IT?
>> TO MAKE IT A MORE FUN PARADE.
>> LET'S PRETEND I ORGANIZED THE
PARADE, I'M THE BOSS OF PARADE,
SO I CAN'T DO AN IRISH ACCEPT SO
I'M GOING TO DO A GERMAN ACCENT
INSTEAD.
WE'LL JUST GO WITH THAT.
WHY DO YOU WANT TO JOIN THE
PARADE?
>> YOU SOUND LIKE JUNE BEREAUT,
OR SOMETHING.
>> I WAS IN CHARACTER.
I CAN'T BREAK IT, SIR.
I'LL DO IT AGAIN. WHY DO YOU
WANT TO JOIN THE PARADE?
>> WE WOULD BE MAGNANIMOUS AND
WE WILL NOT MAKE FUN OF IRISH
PEOPLE BECAUSE WE ARE IRISH.
>> HOW MUCH MONEY WOULD IT TAKE
FOR YOU GUYS TO GO AWAY.
>> WE CAN'T BE BOUGHT.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> BUT I HAVE A LOT OF MONEY.
>> UNLIKE YOU, WE STAND ON
PRINCIPLE.
>> I STAND ON GOLD SHOES.
( LAUGHTER )
WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF YOU WERE
ALLOWED IN THE PARADE?
>> IT WOULD BE-- IT MIGHT BE
ALMOST AS BORING AS IT IS NOW,
BUT WE WOULD JUST MARCH WITH OUR
BANNER.
THANK YOU, YOUR MAJESTY.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
LIKE EVERY OTHER YEAR, THESE
GUYS WOULD ONLY BE ABLE TO
PROTEST THE PARADE, AND EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT THE KEY TO A GOOD
PROTEST IS A GOOD SIGN.
SO, GAELIC IS PRONOUNCED
GAY-LICK FOR A REASON.
>> NO.
>> WE'RE HERE.
WE'RE QUEER, GREEN BEER.
>> THAT'LL NEVER BE IN A PARADE
STOP PEACOCK BLOCKING US.
PRETTY GOOD, RIGHT?
>>I LIKE THAT, I LIKE IT.
>> I HAD TO SEE WHAT THIS PARADE
WAS REALLY ABOUT FOR MYSELF.
PRIDE, CELEBRATING IRISH
HERITAGE.
MADAM, PLEASE.
I TRIED REALLY HARD TO GET INTO
THE SPIRIT OF THINGS.
LOVELY SWEATERS.
BUT MAYBE IT WAS SIMPLER THAN I
THOUGHT.
>> I LIKE BEER.
THAT'S THE SPIRIT OF ST.
PATRICK'S DAY
>> DON'T YOU KNOW IT?
I'M IRISH.
WE DRINK!
THAT'S WHAT WE DO!